when thinking about growth for your app
one of the most important things is the
key flows that you know your users are
going to go through most people who
download your app are not going to come
back later so you really need to get
them to the the WoW moment at the
beginning as soon as possible with your
product so make them see what the value
is so that they will come back again one
of the most important things in AV
testing is also the creative side so
whilst the processes itself is
scientific and you want to use math and
data to get to the right decision
knowing what you can do to move the
metrics that you want to do it's very
much the creative part that goes at the
beginning and without that then you
can't do all of the testing that comes
afterwards if your user is waiting just
a few hundred milliseconds more they
will use your app less it's really
important to be creative for instance if
your app abarkment you wanted more
people to be able to post an ad there
are an infinite number of ways that you
can go about it for instance you might
want a permanent entry point on at the
same point in every single screen in the
app to make sure that people always knew
that they could post an ad and they
always knew where they wanted to go to
do it one of the most important things
that any marketer needs to think about
with their app or product is retention
so it's hard to get people to try out
your app for the first time and if
you're losing users from your app that
can make all of your work that much
harder it's like having a bucket with
holes in it if you're pouring water into
the top your buckets not going to get
full if you have that many holes so
concentrate on filling those holes
increasing user retention and then you
can get more users in when you're trying
to measure retention if you're storing
your own data you need to make sure that
you store when was the first time that
you saw this user so what was the date
when they first turned up then you can
do what's called cohort analysis and
this is just a way of saying for
everyone who installed on a single day
after that what was the likelihood that
they came back on any other given day
another thing that app marketers should
really care about is the number of
people who are actively using your
product too many marketers focus on just
the top of the funnel and getting the
number of downloads up and the number of
new users in but if they're not actively
using the product then they're not doing
you any good
so one that Facebook uses is monthly
active users and that's
the number of people who have opened and
used to rap in the last 30 days when
you're looking at new user acquisition
one of the most important things is the
different sources that are providing you
with new users so for instance there's
organic downloads where people are
coming directly to the App Store maybe
they're searching for a specific term
maybe they're just browsing other ones
include paid channels Facebook for
instance does mobile app install ads if
you go with paid media you'll usually
get a lot of stats from the actual tool
itself so inside of Facebook if you pay
for ads we'll give you really important
key metrics like the reach and number of
impressions that your ads are delivering
as well as the number of installs that
you're getting that's attributed to that
campaign and really key metrics like the
cost that you're paying for each install
for user engagement there's lots of
different ways that you can look at it
the specifics will depend on what your
app is and which market segment you're
in the number of times that a user comes
back inside of a month the daily active
to monthly active ratio is a good
measure of engagement and also the
number of things that they do inside of
the app if you're looking at a shopping
app for instance the number of items
that they view might be a good metric
for engagement the specifics though
we're down to the app itself one of the
most important things that you can do
for growth is get people through the new
user experience as quickly as possible
and into the real well menteur your
product so what is it that really is
going to capture the users attention
what is it about your product that makes
it successful if you have a long signup
flow you're going to reduce the number
of people getting through and that's not
what you want Facebook puts a lot of
effort into its new user registration
flow so when you go to sign up for
Facebook we ask you for as few pieces of
information as we can so that we can get
you to the real point of the product and
that's seeing all of the status updates
and photos and things that your friends
are posting in your newsfeed the most
high-level metrics for paid social are
going to be CPC which is cost per click
that's sort of the usual term that ad
industry uses for engagement on your ads
and what that means is every click is
going to cost you a specific amount of
money it's also important to take into
consideration when you're thinking about
cost per click and how much you're gonna
spend for a click potentially to your
product or website but think
about the lifetime value or LTV of that
particular customer so how much will
they potentially spend long-term if
you're able to acquire them with one
simple add certain platforms like
Twitter use CPE which is cost per
engagement that could be anything that a
user engages with in one of your paid
ads that could be a favorite a retweet
or a direct click-through to your
product or website also just for good
measure it's good to do some basic
research on industry standards and
industry baselines for how well ads
perform so for example if you are
developing a fitness app do some
research on how fitness industry ads
perform on Twitter and if you're getting
a return or an engagement of let's say
1% on your ads you know that you can
compare that to whatever the industry
average is there's no perfect way to
find industry averages or how well you
know relative industries perform on
specific social platforms I'll just say
do some googling do some searching do
some research you're gonna find really
helpful free resources out there and you
can at least find some baselines to go
up and measure your performance against
thinking about a small brand or a small
startup it's really important to embrace
grassroots tactics think constant
engagement think things like giveaways
and contests anything that can move the
needle in the right direction and help
build your social media followers base
it's also important to consider things
like user generated content getting
great content from your users quotes
anything tactical like that can really
pay off and help engage with your
customer base